all right so the left-wing mainstream
media's contempt for this president has
now reached a boiling point and frankly
a point of unhinged insanity this is
especially true for fake news CNN now
four days the Clinton News Network they
have been completely and utterly
obsessed with porn star stormy Daniels
and her salacious claims that she had a
brief affair a one-time encounter with
Donald Trump some twelve or thirteen
years ago you don't believe me take a
look for yourself
detailing on national television an
intimate relationship with Donald Trump
and the effort to conceal it adult film
actress stormy Daniels the White House
briefing expected to begin any moment
now they will certainly face questions
about stormy Daniels the stormy saga
takes a dramatic turn as the porn star
speaks out on her alleged affair with
citizen Trump stormy Daniel Stern has
learned he haven't heard from him about
the stormy Daniels affair adult film
star stormy Daniels breaking her silence
about her alleged affair with President
Trump we were talking I think
understandably and appropriately about
the most serious legal allegations that
stormy Daniels may still me Daniels
stormy Daniels I know you've heard a ton
about that we have to see where that
case goes and what this interview is
about well is that possible to come up
in the stormy Daniels lawsuit will she
be able to say hey look this lawyer is
involved with a whole bunch of different
things here this could be the last nail
in the coffin for me Daniel's it's
causing stormy weather pornstar stormy
Daniels claims President Trump
broke the law had her bullied the stormy
Daniels have the president's number it
sure seems that way
President Trump might have met his match
with stormy Daniels how is stormy
weather in this stormy speaks we're
hearing quite a bit from stormy Daniels
Stormy's in her own words isn't going
anywhere
stormy Daniels has a good lawyer at the
pornstar stormy Daniels was telling the
truth
stormy Daniels is on a tear quick
preview is stormy Daniels interview this
Sunday breaking news that stormy Daniels
stormy Daniels stormy Daniels stormy
Daniels stormy Daniels is stormy Daniels
stormy Daniels stormy Daniels the reason
he can't engage with stormy Daniels is
because she's got his number now of
course the whole network CNN isn't just
focusing in on stormy Daniels well the
network is also giving ample
air time to the claims that are also
made by a former Playboy Playmate Karen
McDougal capped with a particularly
frankly creepy interview with Anderson
Cooper on Thursday listen listen to
these questions and we got a lot more
coming would he would he call you he
would call me I would call him
vice-versa so you had his phone number
when he called did his numbers show up
on the phone were you attracted to him
so does the sex was consensual did he
actually try to hand you money did he
bring up his wife would he talk about
his child his son were you in love with
him yes yeah yeah and do you think he
was in love with you did Donald Trump
ever say to you that he loved you did he
have any nicknames for you what do you
think of the apartment and he showed you
around the apartment how do you feel
being in his apartment
did he ever compare you to any of his
kids did he ever use protection now
meanwhile last night on 60 minutes
Anderson Cooper sat down for his
much-anticipated interview with stormy
Daniels but despite all the build-up and
all the unverified over-the-top claims
made by her lawyer and all the constant
obsessive compulsive media obsession
Cooper's interview did fall flat and
once again came off sorry Anderson this
is creepy take a look
you told don't Trump to turn around and
take off his pants yes and did you yes
so you turn around and pull his pants
down well you know he had underwear on
stuff and I just gave him a couple swats
this was done in a joking manner yes did
you two go out for dinner that night
yeah he had dinner in the room yes what
happened next
and you had sex with her yeah you were
27 he was 60 were you physically
attracted to him no not at all no did
you want to have sex with him no but I
didn't I didn't say no I'm not a victim
I'm not it was entirely consensual oh
yes in an industry where condom use is
an issue did did he use a condom no did
you ask him to now after you had sex
what happened he definitely wanted to
continue to see you hell for sure it
wasn't at that point of business meeting
it was just watching sharpie yeah one
time consensual relationship alleged if
you find all
questions disturbing wait until you see
the interview footage that didn't make
air from 60 minutes overtime I guess
that's the extra tape that they had
nothing to do with it was posted online
and yeah this is tabloid trash
take a look they wanted me to make a
movie and I see of you having sex with
somebody who looked like da and I said
no repeatedly much to their you know
what physically you've seen him in ways
that other people haven't correct and if
need be I can describe that his private
parts the Anderson really considered
this hard news journalism now despite
claims from Stormies lawyer that his
client was ready to disclose a mountain
of evidence about Trump's misconduct the
only potentially newsworthy moment from
the interview was when Stormy's claims
that she was threatened by an
unidentified man following her alleged
affair with mr. trump a one-time affair
but even that claim wasn't backed up
with any evidence no evidence whatsoever
so instead we just got the embarrassing
details of a suppose it or alleged
one-night stand from over 12 years ago
even some in the mainstream media they
are there expressing their utter
disappointment about Henderson's
interviewing and hard-hitting journalism
take a look so I think people thought
there was going to be like a smoking gun
here did we miss something as a young
lawyer I remember being told never
over-promised under-promise over-deliver
and the jury will look positively on you
we have an attorney that's done just the
opposite he over promised he sent out
tweets with pictures of a cd-rom
suggesting some big explosion he told us
two weeks ago that she was threatened
with assault and we would find out more
on 60 minutes when in fact we found out
nothing new on 60 minutes so what are
you waiting for what is the trigger that
has you releasing the physical evidence
I asked you whether there was any
evidence documentary evidence text
messages photo evidence that that
verified that story Daniels had the
affair she claims that she had you said
to me that's a question that miss
Daniels will have to ultimately answer
cut to last night she's asked directly
about this on 60 minutes and she says my
attorney has instructed me not to answer
so does she or doesn't she have this
evidence
all right hell's frozen over I agree
with liberal Jo and the Today Show
Savannah Guthrie now four days right
here on this program we have been
questioning if CNN's soon-to-be
scandal-plagued Chief Jeff Zucker has
turned into the porn king but tonight I
have two back-to-back lewd cringe-worthy
creepy interviews with stormy Daniels
and Karen McDougal again allegations of
a consensual relationship it just looks
like Anderson Cooper is now turned into
CNN's Jerry Springer it's a pretty
compelling comparison let's take a look
you told um Trump to turn around and
take off his pants yes
and did you yes you're young you like
that fun your party girl etc so what's
the problem what's the story you and you
had sex with him yes do you want to be
with her boyfriend no did you want to
have sex with him no but I didn't I
didn't say no you're not interested in
being with him he's just a customer
right well are you interested in being
with him he ended up taking me home you
work in an industry where condom use is
an issue did he use a condom no did you
ask him to now so you had sex with him
yeah I don't know watch out Jerry
Springer creepy Anderson Cooper could be
coming for your job now we're not
kidding look at this CNN was running
images all day long oh there she is porn
star stormy Daniels next to Karen
McDougal we're not making this up
there's a serious note to all this and
aside from Anderson's usually salacious
interviews the mainstream media's
coverage of Daniels and mcdougal is
revealing a huge double standard in this
country
you got allegations from a porn star
about a one-time consensual relationship
with Donald Trump gets round-the-clock
coverage CNN NBC ABC CBS conspiracy TV
MSNBC and others now according to a
study this is where we get serious from
News Buster's
between March 7th and march 25th the
evening newscast from just NBC ABC and
CBS while they dedicated a whopping 40
minutes of airtime to Trump allegations
of a consensual relationship but for
decades the mainstream media has
completely ignored serious stories of
abuse
Juanita Broderick Paula Jones Kathleen
Willey all women that accused a former
President Bill Clinton of serial
predator like gross sexual misconduct
and the media Research Center they
crunch those numbers and according to
their count in 1994 when Paula Jones
came forward with details about Bill
Clinton dropping his pants and exposing
himself to her in a hotel room CBS and
NBC actually ignored the story ABC to
their credit gave a whopping 16 seconds
of coverage and then in 1997 when
Kathleen Willie's allegations about Bill
Clinton became public that he groped and
grabbed and fondled and touched and
kissed her against her will Oh CBS and
NBC gave it one minute and 34 seconds of
coverage ABC didn't touch the story but
in fairness to Ed Bradley who did pass
away he did do an interview on 60
minutes with Kathleen and I believe he
talked to Paul but CNN's evening
newscast dedicated just 26 seconds of
coverage being different CNN then and
now and in 1998 when news broke about
Juanita Broderick's serious claims that
she was raped by Bill Clinton in the 70s
ABC CBS they didn't find a spare second
to cover it meanwhile Lisa Myers from
n-b-c she booked the first interview
with Juanita Broderick and according to
a report from The Washington Post for
over a month
NBC chief Andy lack and others prevented
the interview from airing because they
said they were unable to corroborate her
story right here on the fox news channel
britt hume remember and others were
wearing free Lisa Myers buttons on air
to encourage NBC to release that
extremely important interview when the
mainstream media eventually did cover
the stories of Bill Clinton's accusers
the reporting was often dismissive let's
take a look at some of the clips
provided to us thanks to the media
Research Center yes yes the case was
being fomented by right-wing nuts
and yes she's not a very credible
witness and it's really not a law case
at all I think she's a dubious witness I
really do we've got an awful lot to talk
about this week including the sexual
harassment suit against the president
course and that one's tough to figure
out who's really being arrested
is she not trying to capitalize on this
ineffective - to profit from impugning
the president I have to profess complete
confusion over this entire case why this
is even a case what do you think of mr.
Broadrick story oh I don't believe it at
all anybody wakes 21 years to surface at
a charge like this and there's no
evidence backing up that other than it's
very circumstantial what she may or may
not have told some of her friends at the
time has sworn in in the deposition that
had never happened and all of a sudden
comes forth in this story the story
doesn't deserve to be dignified by being
broadcast and displayed now meanwhile
Matt Drudge on the gorge report had up
on his website today that this 1998
op-ed in the New York Times dismissed
claims against Clinton writing quote
publicly humiliating anyone for
consensual adultery is draconian and
it's wrong I guess that's changed - and
let's not forget that ABC is very own
former Clinton sycophant Georgie
Stephanopoulos he once threatened to end
a person's career if they dared to go
public with Clinton's affair allegations
take a look at this threat what his name
suggests I can send you a fax with names
addresses phone numbers of who you had
an affair with it wouldn't make it true
it is completely if you went on the
radio and said that Bill Clinton
is the father of illegitimate black
child you would be laughed at
you would think you're crazy I guarantee
you that if you do this you'll never
work in democratic politics again maybe
you don't want it I'm not saying it
matters you will be embarrassed before
the national press corps people will
think nobody will believe you and people
will think you're scum
now the point of this is the appalling
double standard in the media continued
all throughout the 2016 election the
liberal press essentially they covered
for then candidate Hillary Clinton all
while throwing her husband's accusers
under the bus we've got the videotape a
trio of women who say Bill Clinton made
unwanted sexual advances in the 80s and
90s mr. Clinton denies it two of the
cases were plagued by factual
discrepancies when it was Bill Clinton's
problem almost in the moment Republicans
tried to make it an issue and it didn't
work so why is it gonna work 20 years
later with his wife I just don't see it
I would like to apologize to those
tramps that have slept with my husband
the rape accusation is decades old and
discredited it's Hillary Clinton who is
the candidate here not Bill Clinton she
was not implicated in any misconduct she
was not someone who was accused even of
doing anything untoward with regard to
these women
it's about groping and fondling and
touching against a woman's will and rape
and rape Donald Trump using that word
unprompted during an interview last
night with Fox News's Sean Hannity
bringing up a discredited and long
denied accusation against former
President Bill Clinton dating back to
1978 when he was Arkansas Attorney
General oh that's pretty pathetic and in
that last clip that we showed Andrea
Mitchell NBC actually edited the online
version to remove her using the word
discredited now what we just showed you
is appalling in just a few minutes by
the way Paul Jones Juanita Broderick
they will react to this double standard
right here in studio to shed some light
on how they have been treated by the
liberal media but it's very clear the
mainstream media shrouds itself in moral
superiority in order to just Lam Donald
Trump but they can get down in the
gutter to defend all things Clinton they
accusations about 12 years ago about an
alleged consensual encounter between
Trump and stormy Daniels and they turn
it into weeks and weeks long scandal but
even up until November of 2016 they were
totally timid as it relates to Bill
Clinton's serial predatory behavior
almost ignoring all the allegations
think of this rape groping fondling
touching kissing against one woman's
will exposing yourself you know when it
comes to Bill Clinton okay they're not
going to fixate on any of it but every
detail of an alleged consensual
relationship as it relates to Donald
Trump over a decade ago journalism is
dead and every day gets very deeper and
deeper alright which brings us to our
next top story that the media will not
talk about tonight and that is their
narrative the Trump Russia collusion
narrative suffered yet another blow
today and in response to Putin's
sanction nerve attack against an agent
against the next by in Great Britain the
Trump administration announced they're
kicking out 60 Russian diplomats in this
country including some who are believed
to be spies operating in the US and a
Russian consulate in Seattle was ordered
closed because of its proximity to a
u.s. naval base the expelled Russians
will have just seven days to leave this
country and while President Trump takes
serious action against Russia all
something we didn't see until the final
weeks of the Obama administration you
might remember when the mainstream media
was predicting that Donald Trump would
do the exact opposite that President
Trump was some kind of shill for
Vladimir Putin or Brennan saying last
week
oh maybe they've got something on Donald
Trump I think he's afraid of the
President of Russia why well I think one
could speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally that they could always roll
out and make his life more difficult
it's so clear at this point that
Vladimir Putin and his associates
somebody has something on Donald Trump
that may be something that turns the key
and the Russia probe is figuring out why
this president is so deferential to
Putin and to Russia and if there is some
sort of compromise that they have on
have Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it her
Lattimore if you will the whole Russian
thing they make these decisions time and
time again in in a way that makes it
appear that they're hostages that he's
that he's a that he's Vladimir Putin's
hostage alright I'm back to disagreeing
with liberal Joe you just heard it
former CIA director Brennan said the
Russians must have something on Trump
okay then if they did why would he do
what he did today I wonder if the
media's gonna publicly eat those words
but don't hold your breath
now if the media's obsession with Russia
Russia Russia followed by their new
obsession with stormy stormy stormy has
taught us anything it's that when the
media is wrong that they'll just move on
to another story never mind